the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video alright my
friends in this video i have some very
exciting news that i must show you as
you all know hbo is developing a new
game of thrones series based on george
rr martin's fire and blood vol 1. this
is a show that has been in the works
since well before game of thrones even
ended if you have been watching all of
my videos then you will know we will
finally see what happened during the
dance of dragons when hbo releases house
of the dragon later this year ever since
hbo made their first announcement about
making a game of thrones successor show
i have made videos about this massive
operation every step of the way
as you all know it has been a very long
night since our watch had ended after
the game of thrones finale well now that
they are done filming house of the
dragon it finally feels like the finish
line is within reach our days of waiting
for a new show are just about over well
soon enough in this video i will show
you what george rr martin has to say
about house of the dragon moving into
their next phase let's have a look at
what he wrote on his not a blog website
only yesterday he said there is exciting
news out of london i am informed that
shooting has wrapped for the first
season of house of the dragon
yes all 10 of their episodes i have seen
rough cuts of the few of them and i'm
loving them
now of course a lot more work needs to
be done special effects color timing the
score and so on and so forth however the
writing the directing and the acting all
look amazing i hope you will like them
as much as i do my hat is off to ryan
condol and miguel sapochnick who are the
co-creators of the show as well as our
amazing cast
so when will you get to see it you ask
when will the dragons finally dance i
wish i could tell you lots of work
remains to be done as i said and covid
makes that difficult will it release
this spring that's unlikely will it be
this summer it could be
what about this fall honestly who knows
you will know when we do
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen it sounds like george r martin
is very happy with how house of the
dragon looks so far now i know some of
you might be thinking well of course he
would say that he is making money from
hbo it's not like he would come out and
say something negative about the show
well you would be right about that
however he doesn't have to say anything
at all
if he honestly did not like it i think
he would have stayed silent like he did
for the later seasons of game of thrones
now i don't know how many of you are
around for that but during the last few
seasons of game of thrones he did just
that not only did he stop working on
game of thrones near the end but he also
stopped talking about the show on social
media i remembered just how silent he
was when the show went off the rails so
i don't feel like he is saying this
because he thinks he has to i honestly
think he loves what he has seen with
house of the dragon thus far
it actually sounds like he is excited
again the same way he was when game of
thrones was about to release its first
season
in fact let me show you what he said
right before game of thrones aired its
first episode this was all the way back
in 2011. thankfully you can still find
his live journal entries on the internet
this is what he said back then
the first two episodes look spectacular
i think especially when seen on the big
screen at caa i have a new 55-inch tv
being installed this week and now i'm
afraid that it's too small these were
the first complete episodes i've seen
and i love them yes there are
differences from the books and of course
there are things missing lines of
dialogue bits of business scenes but
without twice or thrice the running time
there was no way to get everything in
the story is there that's the important
thing
fans who know the novels inside and out
may miss certain things that's sure but
the vast majority of the viewers those
who have never read my novels should do
just fine my hat is off to david and dan
and the team they assembled they've done
an amazing job what he said on his
social media sounds very reminiscent of
what he said when he saw some game of
thrones episodes remember this was back
when game of thrones was amazing and
this was also after game of thrones was
nearly shut down after david and dan
messed up the first episode for those of
you that don't know they actually had to
reshoot most of that first episode as
well as switch out some of the different
actors and even fix the story itself as
far as i know nothing like this has
happened on house of the dragon
thankfully ryan condell and miguel
sapochnick are far more experienced than
dan and dave were when they started on
game of thrones not only that but ryan
condell seems to be a much bigger fan
and student of a song of ice and fire
than dan and dave ever were now if you
heard his interview when him and george
sat down you would have heard just how
invested ryan was in the story he even
goes on to say a song of ice and fire
has influenced the way he writes tell me
about how you guys met a little bit
because i think our audience would
actually really enjoy this i'm a super
fan and i i found the books
at this point over 20 years ago
and i loved them i was a huge
tolkien fan lord of the rings just that
you worshipped at the at the at the
altar of it uh the movies were coming
out and i had i just reread them and i
was in this kind of fantasy mode and i
was like what else is out there and a
friend had recommended hey if you love
tolkien you should really check this out
because it's it's really the only it's
the it's the it's the only thing since
tolkien that really got me up out of my
seat fantasy-wise i've liked other
fantasies i've enjoyed things uh there's
some great classic books out there but
nothing to me held the candle to to
tolkien but this did and it was of
course the first book game of thrones
and i read it and i just i fell all the
way in i was all in like you know i i
couldn't believe how good it was i i
read all three there were three books at
the time storm swords that just had just
been published and i just devoured them
and then went back and devoured them
again and i and it just it became my
favorite thing so and this happened at a
time where i was learning to to write
myself
i was very interested in screenwriting
i'd written a couple of scripts i was
starting to try to make a a career of
this i was in my early 20s and um you
know cut to a number of years later i'm
not i've now broken in i still love
these books i'm a huge fan of the
television show i'm watching it all i
tried to get at some point i tried to
get my agents to get me a staff writer
job on the show and they were like they
don't have staff writers it's just the
two of them write the whole show
so um i respected him so much and
actually learned so much from him as a
writer because i i mean i credit even
though the the the books are prose books
george started as a dramatic writer a
screenwriter in television the books are
written in this commentary dave you've
read them they're written in this
incredibly cinematic way with hooks at
the end of chapters there's dialogue i
mean it's written you could very easily
just put slug lines into those books and
create scenes out of them it's not a
novelistic style of writing so i learned
a lot about character and storytelling
and atmosphere and theme and all these
you know
literary tools like you know
foreshadowing and how to you know how to
write prophecy compelling prophecy that
doesn't seem you know uh
uh dinky or foregone conclusion all
these things that i i still use today
that i learned from those books so it
was just really exciting for me to be
able to meet george and then we and then
we hit it off and then you know on down
the road we go you know some you know
five six seven years later turned into a
job offer which still i mean as still it
still
blows my mind that i'm that i'm sitting
here doing the show i for one think the
show is in great hands and i believe
george feels that same way as well i
think we're about to be in for one hell
of a ride and i hope all of you stick
with me so we can ride this thing out
together like i always say make sure you
subscribe now if you want to stay up to
date on any and all information or
updates about game of thrones house of
the dragon or a song of ice and fire i
still have a lot more videos to make as
we get closer and closer to the release
date
as always i hope i will see all of you
back here for those videos as well
have a great day everyone i will see you
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you